world famous artist Vincent van Gogh
achieved widespread of claim only after
he died he never got to enjoy his
success or see the powerful influence of
his paintings on other artists this
morning we meet another artist who once
feared he could face obscurity but as
Nancy Chen shows us New York painter
Scott Khan has found sudden success late
in life and he's enjoying every minute
of it
how many pieces do you have left at this
point well that's a good question I I
don't really know painter Scott Khan
worries he's running low on inventory
the stacks used to come out here and the
racks were all filled up these days the
76 year old's work is snatched up
decades worth of paintings once rarely
noticed I was convinced I would die in
obscurity and poverty and that they
would carve me out of there in a pine
box this painting is called the curtains
parted can't spend his life as the
definition of a starving artist but his
dedication always remained firm it was
my path I had no choice before this
relatively Newfound success
you were close to zero I'd been down to
zero many times below zero negative zero
that all changed dramatically a few
years ago when he struck up an unlikely
friendship with a reclusive artist named
Matthew Wong I think it was just a
spiritual connection a huge respect
for each other and each other's work
Wong was an up-and-coming painter who
began finding enormous success
success kick-started cons he bought a
painting of mine
and he put it on his Instagram feed and
that's what triggered this enormous
interest in my work people started
streaming through my studio door
collectors dealers other artists and it
went on Non-Stop five years ago how much
was a painting of your selling for well
just a few thousand dollars and how much
did your last painting sell for
one million dollars
sadly Wong never got to see his friend's
accomplishments he took his own life in
2019 at the age of 35. what did Matthew
Wong mean to you Matthew was a soul mate
to me and as Khan continued continues on
the path Wong helped carve his Newfound
recognition is a testament to unwavering
commitment he's very dedicated and
obsessed you need Obsession Mary Boone
is a celebrated art dealer who's worked
with iconic painters like John Michelle
Basquiat she says she's not surprised by
Khan's achievements how rare is it for
an artist to achieve this kind of
success this late in their career
if you're a great artist which I think
is God is hopefully it comes during your
lifetime how would you describe Scott's
work I mean it has primitive aspects to
it it had spiritual why do you think it
speaks to people so much I think because
of the dreamlike quality I think people
are interested in things that they don't
completely understand Khan doesn't
pretend to understand his late success
he's just happy that it'll allow him to
continue his passion I have two
priorities
one is life
and the other is freedom I love my
painting I will never stop painting but
life is what a journey it is and at this
point in my life
that has become more important to me
than anything else
since we sat down with Khan one of his
paintings has sold for a new personal
record
1.2 million dollars despite his recent
success he still lives a Frugal life
even now and says he was always
satisfied simply by his work and you
consider the fact that just a few years
ago he was living in his cousin's attic
yeah and just making it by day by day
and now he's selling a painting for 1.2
million dollars I know there are certain
comparisons that are Blasphemous in the
art world but there is a like a van Gogh
quality to some of his art like that
starry night variation aspect little
dreary
um but also has depth
really really it's gorgeous it's
gorgeous and so vibrant but what I love
is that this is really the power of
social media had that other person his
friend not posted a picture of his art
none of this would have happened but it
almost didn't matter because he says he
does it for the love of his art form and
it's beautiful art it is that's right
thank you so much Nancy Chen we
appreciate you we'll be right back